john is really upset that his local
mcdonald's closed down for renovations
he's having a hard time
what that bothers you i drove by
and it was this nice like old-fashioned
cottage-looking mcdonald's you know has
been here forever and they're gonna make
it look like
all the other ones like those gray
lifeless
buildings so uh yeah i was very upset by
this robin it was one of the perks
don't [ __ ] me how many times a week
you eat mcdonald's
a few i'd say probably three
john goes the other mcdonald's near me
are not as good what makes
your mcdonald's that's near you better
than the other
yeah i mean who wouldn't know that you
got to eat a lot of [ __ ] mcdonald's
to taste the difference
it's fresh it's hot again they get it
right so yeah it is the service as well
as the food
john have you fantasized about running a
mcdonald's because gary told me you have
like that's yeah i i thought about
buying one actually
what would you be your management
philosophy to what are the things you
would improve
i i would insist that people know what
they want when they come in
versus wondering what's on the menu and
this and that
i'm gonna educate how are you gonna do
that well when they come in and they
look a little lost i'll put them on a
different i'd have different lines
if you're like new to the place or if
you've been there a few times
what if they get inside and start
pondering what they're gonna order would
you be
changing their mind i would i would have
someone come over to them and
escort them into the beginner line and
they'd have to wait there
and they could because because if you've
been there for a few times you don't
deserve you should know the treatment
first you gotta spot the beginners who
are come and
those are the skinny people once
somebody gets plump enough you know to
put them right in the other line
john told me once when he's ordering at
mcdonald's
he will box out the other customers to
get his orders before the customers can
even order so in other words
until that order comes out i will take
one step to the right
to let the next person come up but i
will stay there
waiting for my food and you know
i can get a view of the kitchen and see
if they're doing it correctly
because if you don't do that a lot of
times they'll just forget about you
and again because i special order it may
not be correct
and i don't want to you know what is
your special order
what is your special order people want
to know mcdonald's i get a
double quarter pound or plain with no
cheese large size that's the order
which means two patties on a on
on on the bun nothing on it no no
ketchup no pickles nothing on it
an order of fries and a drink which
should take about three seconds to make
because there's not
cheese there's nothing so what happens
sometimes is they deliver your bag of
food you sit down at the table and you
go
oh no there's cheese i told these
[ __ ]
no no you're wrong what i'll do and this
is obnoxious i admit it
if i'm at the drive-thru let's say and
they give me my order
i do not pull away until i open the bag
inspect the burger make sure that
there's no cheese on it
and then i go and if there is cheese on
it i hand it right back
all right so role play with me sir would
you please
move to spot number one sir you but you
got it wrong the first time so how do i
know that you're gonna get it correct
the second time
because we're highly trained at
mcdonald's university and we know what
we're doing sir would you please
move to lane once as long as i know that
my burger will be the way that i ordered
it
and by the way sir if there is cheese on
your burger let's say we [ __ ] up
how about you just scrape the cheese off
and get and get on your way
it doesn't work that way because the
cheese gets so melted into the burger
around to the bun
it completely destroys the uh the
experience that i'm looking for in
getting my plain double quarter pounder
you know what's interesting to me they
probably know john's car he's so
obnoxious
and they can see it in the line and they
go oh no
i walked up one day and i didn't even
order
they just put it in and say 8 47. i was
like oh my god
you know why they renovated john's local
mcdonald's they were afraid his ass
wouldn't fit through the door he's been
going there
you